und wir schauen in die Ukraine denn eine
Nacht beschäftigt eine Nachricht
beschäftigt uns heute morgen ganz
besonders Präsident wolodemir selenski
der will Millionen Soldaten
zusammenziehen eine Million um genau zu
sein um den Süden des Landes
zurückzuobern das hat seinen
Verteidigungsminister jetzt enthüllt und
Präsident der soll den Befehl schon
gegeben haben
wie lange wird der Krieg in der Ukraine
noch dauern jetzt wurde ein Plan des
ukrainischen Präsidenten enthüllt
bologneselensky will den Süden des
Landes zurückerobern und dafür eine
Million Soldaten zusammenziehen laut dem
ukrainischen Verteidigungsminister hat
selenski den Befehl zur Rückeroberung
bereits gegeben er selensky Plan ein
Hinweis darauf dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine noch sehr lange dauern könnte
unterdessen halten die Bombenangriffe an
in der Ostukraine sind bei einem Angriff
am Samstag mindestens 15 Menschen
getötet worden in der Stadt scharsevia
wurden mehrere Wohngebäude bei einem
Angriff zerstört Rettungskräfte suchten
am Sonntag in den Trümmern nach
Überlebenden in den letzten Wochen
musste die Ukraine gerade in der Region
luhansk im Osten des Landes herbe
Verluste hinnehmen mittlerweile ist der
gesamte Teil unter der Kontrolle von
Kreml Diktator Wladimir Putin
kleine Truppen versuchen derzeit die
zweite donbassregion Donezk zu erobern
seit Tagen wird insbesondere die Stadt
slofiansk fast rund um die Uhr
bombardiert
im Osten der Ukraine gehen die schweren
Kämpfe weiter die Russen vermelden neue
Vorstöße
und jetzt der selensky-plan eine Million
Soldaten in den Süden zu schicken
und Deutschland weigert sich weiter
Transportkapazitäten der Ukraine zur
Verfügung zu stellen der Transport
Panzer Fuchs wurde gerade von der
Bundesregierung abgelehnt
unterdessen gehen die Kämpfe in der
Ukraine weiter und die Frage lautet wie
lange wird der Krieg noch dauern